Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. In 1987, London-based lawyer and part-time DJ Phil Green cemented a new career endeavour by founding his own modelling agency, aptly titled Supermodel Agency. By 2017, Phil was entering his 30th year in the industry and Supermodel Agency was a major success, representing a large catalogue of glamour models, promo girls and Instagram influencers.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目简介。1987年，常驻伦敦的律师兼兼职DJ菲尔·格林（Phil Green）创立了自己的模特公司，以此开启了全新的职业生涯，公司取了一个十分贴切的名字——超级模特公司（Supermodel Agency）。到2017年，菲尔迎来了他在该行业的第30个年头，超级模特公司也获得了巨大成功，旗下代理了大量迷人模特、促销女孩和Instagram网红。
Many were featured in erotic calendars and men's magazines like FHM, Maxim, Loaded, Nuts and Zoo Weekly, with the elite appearing in the more illustrious Playboy. Several earned a level of popularity as Page 3 Girls, a British tabloid tradition where female glamour models were featured topless on the aforementioned page of The Sun, Daily Mirror and Daily Star newspapers. Phil primarily ran his business online, meeting with aspiring models at private residences to assess if they were suitable to join his books. His email inbox was consistently filled with requests from clients from across the world
许多人曾在情色日历以及《FHM》、《Maxim》、《Loaded》、《Nuts》和《Zoo Weekly》等男性杂志上亮相，其中精英更是登上了更负盛名的《花花公子》（Playboy）。有几人作为“第3版女郎”（Page 3 Girls）赢得了相当高的人气。这是一个英国小报传统，女性魅力模特会在《太阳报》、《每日镜报》和《每日邮报》的前述版面上半裸出镜。菲尔主要在线上经营业务，会在私人住所与有志成为模特的人会面，以评估她们是否适合加入其公司。他的收件箱里塞满了来自世界各地客户的请求。
who required models for a variety of purposes, including photo shoots, commercials, corporate events and parties. No request was off limits as Phil sent his personnel to a range of jobs, from fetish shoots and jelly wrestling competitions to trade shows and motor races. Models with a significant following on social media would occasionally be selected to audition for a role on television as a game show hostess, or to compete in a reality series like Love Island or Celebrity Big Brother. Phil Green took every opportunity to network with the rich and famous, arranging parties
这些客户需要模特用于各种目的，包括照片拍摄、商业广告、企业活动和派对。没有任何请求是越界的，菲尔将他的人员派往各种工作岗位，从恋物癖拍摄、果冻摔跤比赛到贸易展和赛车。在社交媒体上拥有大量粉丝的模特偶尔会被挑选去试镜电视剧的主持人角色，或参加诸如《爱情岛》（Love Island）或《名人老大哥》（Celebrity Big Brother）等真人秀节目。菲尔·格林抓住一切机会与富豪名流建立人脉，在伦敦时尚的夜总会安排派对。
at London's trendy nightclubs where he would spend the evening in the VIP area surrounded by a bevy of attractive women half his age. If one of his models hooked up with a celebrity or sports star, Phil would put them in touch with tabloid newspaper journalists and earn a cut of the profit for the scoop. He also pocketed 20% of the sales from photos depicting his models in compromising situations, such as accidental flashes of public nudity, most of which were staged. On the morning of Wednesday, July 12, 2017, Phil sat down at his computer to check his work emails.
他会在那里在贵宾区度过整个夜晚，周围环绕着一群比他年轻一半的迷人女性。如果他的某位模特与名流或体育明星勾搭上，菲尔就会让她们与小报记者牵线搭桥，并从中分得独家新闻的利润。他还将模特在狼狈情况下（如不小心走光，其中大部分是摆拍）的照片销售额的20%收入囊中。2017年7月12日星期三上午，菲尔坐在电脑前查看工作邮件。
These inbox contained the usual array of offers from clients seeking models, but there was one email that stood out from all the others. It was sent from an organisation titled The Black Death Group, and began, We've got Chloe Ailing. Chloe Ailing never intended to be in the limelight. Her initial focus was on academia, studying law, business and psychology at A level, before moving into sports science. Regarded as a conventional beauty, she began modelling at 18 years old, complemented for
这些收件箱里有来自寻求模特的客户的寻常邀约，但有一封邮件在所有邮件中脱颖而出。它由一个名为“黑死病集团”（The Black Death Group）的组织发送，开头写道：“我们已经抓到了克洛伊·艾林（Chloe Ayling）。”克洛伊·艾林从未打算成为聚光灯下的焦点。她最初的重心是学术，在A-Level（高级水平考试）阶段学习法律、商业和心理学，随后转向运动科学。她被视为一位传统的美女，18岁开始当模特，因其圆润、女性化的面庞而备受赞誉。
her round, feminine face that was framed by thick, long, wavy blonde hair and a slender, though shapely figure. Standing at just five foot three inches tall, she wasn't suitable for modelling high fashion, which generally required a minimum height of five foot eight. Instead, Chloe set her sights on glamour and commercial modelling. The teenager established an online presence by featuring in strip football challenge videos on YouTube, where she was tasked with kicking a soccer ball in high heels to her male teammates, who would then take a shot at goal.
她的面庞被浓密、长而微卷的金发所环绕，身形纤细却曲线玲珑。她身高只有五英尺三英寸（约1.6米），不适合做高级时装模特，高级时装通常要求最低身高为五英尺八英寸（约1.73米）。相反，克洛伊将目光投向了魅力模特和商业模特。这位少年通过在YouTube上出演脱衣足球挑战视频在网络上建立了一定的知名度，在视频中，她必须穿着高跟鞋将足球踢给她的男队友，然后男队友会向球门射门。
If they missed, Chloe would have to remove a piece of clothing, the game carrying on until she was standing in the open field as naked as YouTube's rules would allow. She also took part in prank videos where she participated in staged practical jokes, which involved her having to strip down to her underwear. Chloe didn't earn much for taking part in these videos, but they raised her profile and led to better jobs. In August 2016, two months after turning 19, Chloe signed a contract with the Supermodel Agency and became one of Phil Green's most prominent models, amassing hundreds of thousands
如果他们没射进，克洛伊就得脱掉一件衣服，游戏一直持续到她像YouTube规则允许的那样赤身裸体地站在开阔的场地上。她还参加了恶作剧视频，参与事先安排好的恶作剧，其中涉及她不得不脱到只剩内衣。克洛伊参与这些视频并没有赚多少钱，但它们提升了她的知名度，并为她带来了更好的工作。2016年8月，在年满19岁两个月后，克洛伊与超级模特公司签了合同，成为了菲尔·格林最著名的模特之一，通过发布各种衣着暴露、诱人的照片，在她的Instagram主页上积累了数十万粉丝。
of followers on her Instagram page by posting a variety of scantily clad, seductive photos. She worked constantly, eventually earning up to £500 per magazine shoot and becoming a popular choice for the Daily Star, the only newspaper that continued to feature Page 3 girls. It therefore came as no surprise to Phil Green when in March 2017, he received an email from an Italian photographer named Andre Lattio, personally requesting Chloe ailing for a glamour photo shoot in Paris. His studio was titled Basime Afique and he wanted Chloe to model some leather apparel
她工作不断，最终每场杂志拍摄能赚取高达500英镑，并成为《每日星报》（Daily Star）的热门选择——这是唯一一家继续刊登“第3版女郎”的报纸。因此，当菲尔·格林在2017年3月收到一封来自意大利摄影师安德烈·拉蒂奥（Andre Lattio）的电子邮件，指名要求克洛伊·艾林前往巴黎进行魅力写真拍摄时，他一点也不感到意外。他的工作室名为“Basime Afique”，他希望克洛伊为摩托车杂志广告拍摄一些皮革服饰。
for a motorcycle magazine advert. Lattio was straightforward and professional as he detailed the shoot to Phil, explaining Chloe would be posing on a motorbike in front of a green screen so that background scenery could be digitally added later. The job included flights, overnight accommodation at the four-star Hotel Madeleine Plaza in central Paris, a spa treatment and spending money. As part of his role as a modeling agent, Phil Green was expected to research any potential clients and verify that the jobs they were offering his models were genuine.
拉蒂奥在向菲尔详细介绍拍摄时表现得直截了当且专业，解释说克洛伊将在一台绿幕前的摩托车上摆姿势，以便稍后可以在数字上添加背景风景。这份工作包括机票、位于巴黎市中心四星级玛德琳广场酒店（Hotel Madeleine Plaza）的过夜住宿、水疗护理和零花钱。作为模特经纪人职责的一部分，菲尔·格林本应调查任何潜在客户，并核实他们为模特提供的工作是否真实。
In his book, Confessions of a Model Agent, Phil said, I checked Andre Lattio's address and this was perfectly legitimate, even to the point of looking at Google Maps to find the location. I asked him to send me pictures of previous work he had done to which he duly obliged. He even sent me a picture of his studio and there above the studio door were the words Basime Afique, a little Italian temper in the heart of France, exactly as he said. Satisfied he had confirmed the legitimacy of the job and client, Phil agreed to send Chloe to France for the shoot.
菲尔在他的书《模特经纪人的自白》（Confessions of a Model Agent）中说道：“我检查了安德烈·拉蒂奥的地址，这完全是合法的，甚至精确到了查看谷歌地图来寻找这个位置。我请他发给我他以前作品的照片，他也照办了。他甚至发给我一张他工作室的照片，工作室门上方正是‘Basime Afique’几个字，正宗的法式风情中带着一丝意大利人的脾气，正如他所说。”菲尔确信工作和客户的合法性后，便同意送克洛伊去法国拍摄。
Chloe was thrilled by the opportunity. The prospect of travel, glamour and adventure was exactly what had enticed her into the world of modeling in the first place and having never been to Paris, she was itching to explore the famed city. Phil told Chloe that despite having her measurements taken upon joining Supermodel Agency, she had to come in for a second fitting as Lattio requested her exact sizing for the custom made motorcycle leathers she would be wearing in the shoot. Phil was known as the man with the tape measure and insisted on measuring all the models himself,
克洛伊对这个机会感到兴奋不已。旅行、魅力和冒险的前景正是最初将她吸引进模特世界的原因，而且她从未去过巴黎，正渴望探索这座著名的城市。菲尔告诉克洛伊，尽管在加入超级模特公司时已经量过尺寸，但由于拉蒂奥要求她提供拍摄时将穿的定制摩托车皮衣的准确尺码，她必须再去进行第二次试穿。菲尔被称为“带卷尺的人”，坚持亲自测量所有模特的数据。
claiming to have been duped in the past by women who lied about their dimensions. Chloe reluctantly agreed. To ensure she had as much time as possible to experience the foreign city, Chloe requested the earliest flight available to Paris and the latest one to leave. Upon landing on the morning of Thursday, April 20, a driver was awaiting her arrival at the gate, holding a sign with her name in big black letters. She was driven to her hotel where she checked in and deposited her luggage before heading out to see the Eiffel Tower.
他声称过去曾被谎报尺寸的女性欺骗过。克洛伊很不情愿地同意了。为了确保有尽可能多的时间体验这座外国城市，克洛伊要求购买飞往巴黎最早的航班和离开时最晚的航班。4月20日星期四早晨落地后，一名司机在登机口等候她的到来，手里举着写有她名字的大黑字牌子。她被送到酒店，办理入住并放下行李，然后出发去参观埃菲尔铁塔。
As she walked the three and a half kilometres to the famous landmark, Chloe video called Phil on her mobile phone so she could show him the sights. She reached the tower and took a selfie underneath before moving off to have dinner on her own at a nearby restaurant. Chloe arrived back to her hotel later that evening, but her plans of a relaxing night were interrupted by the screech of emergency beagle sirens outside. She received a text message from a friend alerting her to a headline that had appeared online, which read,
当她步行三公里半前往这座著名地标时，克洛伊用手机给菲尔打了视频电话，这样她就能让他看看沿途的风景。她到达铁塔并在下方自拍了一张，随后动身去附近的一家餐厅独自吃晚餐。克洛伊那天傍晚回到酒店，但她想要度过一个放松之夜的计划被外面刺耳的紧急救护车警笛声打断了。她收到了一条朋友发来的短信，提醒她注意网上出现的一条头条新闻，上面写着：
Terra hits Paris as policemen shot on the Champs Elysees. Chloe bunkered down in her room as news of the shooting began to filter through. Around the time she had been eating dinner, a gunman wielding an AK-47 rifle roamed the Champs Elysees shopping boulevard one kilometre away. One police officer was killed, and two others, as well as a German tourist, were seriously injured. The perpetrator was shot dead and found to be carrying a list of police station addresses he had planned to ambush, along with a note praising jihadist militant group ISIS.
“恐怖主义袭击巴黎，香榭丽舍大街警察遭枪击。”随着枪击事件的消息开始传开，克洛伊躲在房间里不敢出门。大约在她吃晚餐的时候，一名手持AK-47步枪的枪手在一公里外的香榭丽舍大街购物大道上流窜。一名警察丧生，另外两人以及一名德国游客受重伤.凶手被当场击毙，人们发现他随身带着一份他计划袭击的警察局地址列表，以及一张赞扬圣战激进组织“伊斯兰国”（ISIS）的便条。
As such, the incident was declared a terror attack. The next morning, Chloe received a phone call from Andrea Lazio, the photographer overseeing the motorcycle photo shoot. He informed Chloe that his studio had been ransacked during the chaos of the terror attack, and that all of his camera equipment and lighting gear had been stolen. Lazio had no choice but to cancel the shoot, and was sending a prepaid taxi to collect Chloe from the hotel and take her back to the airport. Frustrated but understanding, Chloe finished her breakfast and checked out, before jumping
因此，该事件被宣布为恐怖袭击。第二天早上，克洛伊接到负责摩托车写真拍摄的摄影师安德烈·拉蒂奥（Andrea Lazio）的电话。他通知克洛伊，他的工作室在恐怖袭击的混乱中被洗劫一空，他所有的相机设备和灯光器材都被偷了。拉蒂奥别无选择，只能取消拍摄，并派了一辆预付费出租车去酒店接克洛伊回机场。克洛伊感到沮丧但表示理解，她吃完早餐并办理了退房手续，然后跳进了一辆等在酒店前方的汽车里。
into a car that was waiting at the front of the hotel. It wasn't until she arrived at the airport that Chloe realized she had gotten into the wrong car. The driver demanded cash for the trip, but she didn't have any as she had been expecting to receive her expenses later that day. Chloe scrolled through her mobile phone until she found the email containing Andrea Lazio's contact number and promptly called him, passing the phone to the driver so the two of them could resolve the situation.
直到抵达机场，克洛伊才意识到自己上了错误的汽车。司机索要车费，但她身上一分钱也没有，因为她本指望当天晚些时候拿到报销费用。克洛伊在手机里翻找，直到找到包含安德烈·拉蒂奥联系电话的邮件并迅速拨通，把电话递给司机，以便两人解决这一状况。
After a conversation in French, the driver informed Chloe she was to wait in the car until Lazio arrived with the payment. Eventually, a lean Caucasian man with cropped dark hair wearing sporty sunglasses appeared at the window, introducing himself as Andre Lazio. For an experienced senior photographer, Lazio appeared remarkably young to Chloe, seemingly under 30 years old. He paid the driver and apologized profusely to Chloe both for canceling the shoot and for the mix-up with the car.
经过一番法语对话后，司机通知克洛伊在车里等着，直到拉蒂奥带着钱赶到。终于，一个身材消瘦、留着短短深色头发、戴着运动太阳镜的白人男子出现在车窗旁，自我介绍说自己叫安德烈·拉蒂奥。对克洛伊来说，作为一个经验丰富的高级摄影师，拉蒂奥显得异常年轻，看起来似乎不到30岁。他付了车费，并为取消拍摄以及汽车的乌龙事件向克洛伊连声道。
He seemed agitated and keen to get going, giving Chloe her promise to £90 for expenses before leaving her to wait several hours for her scheduled flight home. Although she didn't get to complete the shoot, the trip wasn't a complete ride-off for Chloe. Back in London, The Daily Star newspaper wrote an article about how one of their top Page 3 models was caught up in Paris during the recent terror attack, accompanying the story with a topless picture of Chloe. A few months later, Chloe was on assignment in Dubai, which involved partying with the client, attending nightclubs and frolicking on the beach, when she received a call from
他看起来有些焦虑，急着离开，在给克洛伊90英镑的费用承诺后，便留下她等待几个小时后按计划飞回家的航班。尽管没能完成拍摄，但这次旅行对克洛伊来说并非完全是一次泡汤的经历。回到伦敦后，《每日星报》撰写了一篇文章，讲述了他们的一位顶级“第3版女郎”如何在最近的恐怖袭击中被困在巴黎，并在报道中配发了克洛伊的半裸照片。几个月后，克洛伊正在迪拜执行任务，其中包括与客户派对、光顾夜总会和在海滩上嬉戏，这时她接到了菲尔·格林的电话。
Phil Green with some good news. Andre Lazio had rescheduled the Motorcycle magazine photo shoot. Finding Paris too dangerous, he had since relocated his studio to his home country of Italy, with the shoot taking place in the northern city of Milan on July 11. With a couple of weeks after Chloe's 20th birthday, Chloe had never been to Milan and was excited to visit the city deemed the fashion capital of the world, again requesting the earliest arrival flight possible to make the most of the trip. Lazio offered a £900 payment up front and sent images of his new Milan-based studio
电话里带来了好消息：安德烈·拉蒂奥重新安排了摩托车杂志的写真拍摄。由于发现巴黎太危险，他已将工作室搬回了他的祖国意大利，拍摄定于7月11日在北部城市米兰进行。在克洛伊20岁生日后几天，从未去过米兰的克洛伊兴奋不已，渴望访问这座被视为世界时尚之都的城市，并再次要求购买最早到达的航班以充分利用这次旅行。拉蒂奥提前提供了900英镑的报销款，并发送了他位于米兰的新工作室的照片。
which bore the same Bessemer fake signage as his one in Paris. Phil checked the studio's address on Google Maps, confirming the building existed and matched the details Lazio had provided. On Tuesday, July 11, Chloe flew into Milan and checked into the Best Western Plus Hotel on the Piazza Lima, where Lazio had arranged complimentary spa treatments and breakfast for her. She went shopping and purchased some bikinis for an upcoming trip to Ibiza, where she planned to take some beachside photos for her Instagram account.
照片上的招牌与他在巴黎的那家一样，都是“Basime Afique”。菲尔在谷歌地图上核对该工作室的地址，确认该建筑确实存在并且与拉蒂奥提供的信息相符。7月11日星期二，克洛伊飞往米兰，入住位于利马广场（Piazza Lima）的贝斯特韦斯特普拉斯酒店（Best Western Plus Hotel），拉蒂奥在那里为她安排了免费的水疗护理和早餐。她去购物并买了几套比基尼，准备用于即将到来的伊比沙岛之旅，她计划在那里拍一些海滩照片发到Instagram账号上。
The next morning, Chloe awoke early and dressed in a pink chenille bodysuit, designer jeans, sneakers, a pink leather jacket and a cap. She packed her suitcase and at 8.30am checked out of her hotel to begin the 20 minute taxi ride to the photography studio. After that night, as midnight approached in England, Bayada Eiling was struck with worry. Her daughter Chloe was due to land at Gatwick Airport hours earlier at 9.30pm but she had not arrived home and there had been no word from her. This was unusual as Chloe would always ring her mother to keep her updated on her travels.
第二天早上，克洛伊醒得很早，穿了一身粉色雪尼尔连体衣、设计师牛仔裤、运动鞋、一件粉色皮夹克和一顶帽子。她收拾好行李，于上午8点30分退了房，开始乘出租车前往摄影工作室，车程20分钟。在那天深夜，随着英国时间接近午夜，巴亚达·艾林（Bayada Ayling）陷入了焦虑。她的女儿克洛伊本应在几小时前的晚上9点30分降落在盖特威克机场，但她并没有回家，也没有任何音讯。这很不寻常，因为克洛伊总是会给母亲打电话，让她随时了解自己的行程。
Bayada phoned Phil Green but he hadn't heard from Chloe either, even though she would call him after a photo shoot to let him know how it had gone. Phil checked the status of Chloe's flight from Milan and confirmed that it had landed in Gatwick on schedule. Knowing she had plans to fly to Ibiza the next day, Phil suggested she may have decided to stay in Milan another day and fly directly to Ibiza from there. Bayada had a hard time believing her daughter would make such a radical change without notifying her first and considered the possibility that Chloe had lost her phone.
巴亚达给菲尔·格林打了电话，但菲尔也没有克洛伊的消息，尽管她通常在拍摄结束后会打电话告诉他情况如何。菲尔查了克洛伊从米兰起飞的航班状态，确认它已按时在盖特威克降落。得知她有计划第二天飞往伊比沙岛，菲尔推测她可能决定在米兰多呆一天，并从那里直接飞往伊比沙岛。巴亚达很难相信女儿在没有事先通知她的情况下会做出如此激烈的改变，并考虑了克洛伊手机丢失的可能性。
Phil proposed they wait until the morning before making inquiries about Chloe's whereabouts, expecting a logical explanation to arise in the meantime and Bayada reluctantly agreed. The following morning of Wednesday, July 12, there had still been no contact from Chloe. Phil called the airline and discovered there was no record of her checking in for her flight from Milan. He turned on his computer to check whether Andre Lazio had emailed through any revised plans for the photo shoot and as he scanned his inbox, one email caught his eye, at red. Hi, Phil Green, I go by the name M.D.
菲尔建议他们等到早晨再打听克洛伊的下落，预计在此期间会有合理的解释出现，巴亚达很不情愿地同意了。第二天早上，即7月12日星期三，仍然没有克洛伊的任何联系。菲尔给航空公司打电话，发现没有她从米兰登机回国的任何记录。他打开电脑，查看安德烈·拉蒂奥是否通过电子邮件发过任何修改后的拍摄计划。当他浏览收件箱时，一封邮件引起了他的注意，内容如下：你好，菲尔·格林，我化名M.D.。
I am a mid-high-level contract killer working for Black Death Group. Chloe has been taken and is currently under my wings and as long as I live, nothing will happen to her. I give my word. It went on to explain that Chloe was set to be auctioned as a sex slave on the dark web the following Sunday, unless Phil raised a ransom of €300,000. He was instructed to get the money from three men Chloe had named, two of whom Phil recognised as supermodel agency clients and the other, Rory, who he did not know.
我是一名黑死病集团的中高级合同杀手。克洛伊已经被绑架，目前在我的羽翼之下，只要我活着，她就不会有事。我向你保证。信中接着解释说，如果菲尔筹集不到30万欧元的赎金，克洛伊将于下一个星期日在暗网上被当作性奴拍卖。他被指示从克洛伊提到的三名男子那里筹集资金，其中两人被菲尔认出是超级模特公司的客户，另一名叫罗里（Rory）的人他不认识。
M.D. stated he was risking his life by writing to Phil and protecting Chloe, but was unable to release her as, quote, The sentence for that would be death, for both myself and Chloe as a part of a rule that no merchandise leaves Black Death unpaid. Phil responded to the email with a single word, received. The Black Death Group alleged to be an organised crime group from Eastern Europe that dealt with weapons, drugs, bombings, assassinations, provision of mercenaries, false identity creation, human trafficking and dark web sales.
M.D.声称他写信给菲尔并保护克洛伊是在冒着生命危险，但无法释放她，因为“引用的惩罚将是死刑，对我自己和克洛伊都是如此，这是‘没有商品能未付款离开黑死病’这一规则的一部分。”菲尔用一个词回复了这封电子邮件：“已收到”。黑死病集团据称是一个来自东欧的有组织犯罪集团，从事武器、毒品、爆炸案、暗杀、雇佣兵提供、虚假身份制造、人口贩卖和暗网销售。
To remain incognito, Black Death did not advertise their sex slave auctions to the masses and would change web addresses whenever their site received too much traffic. Those who managed to find Black Death's website were greeted by a drawing of 11 ominous figures wearing long robes and masks associated with plague doctors in the 1300s. The masks featured a six-inch-long black beak that was traditionally filled with pleasant spelling plants and spices to conceal the stench of corpses. The Black Death website featured an auction page which was only accessible to users who had been recommended by current members.
为了保持匿名，黑死病集团并不向大众宣传他们的性奴拍卖，并且每当他们的网站获得过多流量时就会更改网址。那些设法找到黑死病网站的人会看到一幅画，上面画着11个不祥的人物，穿着长袍，戴着1300年代瘟疫医生所戴的面具。面具的特点是一个六英寸长的黑色鸟嘴，传统上里面塞满了气味芬芳的植物和香料，以掩盖尸体的恶臭。黑死病网站设有一个拍卖页面，仅对经现任成员推荐的用户开放。
It advertised a range of women referred to as merchandise that were available to purchase, with the youngest the most expensive. Each auction profile included a starting bid, photos and details of the woman's height, weight and size. According to the group, a doctor was on staff to test the captives for sexually transmitted diseases and virginity, with those declared as pure commanding a higher price. The auctions occurred in Europe, but the victim could be delivered to the winning bidder anywhere in the world, and customers with a specific woman in mind could also pay a significant
它宣传了一系列被称为“商品”的可供购买的女性，其中最年轻的最贵。每个拍卖资料都包括起拍价、照片以及女性的身高、体重和尺寸细节。据该组织称，有专职医生负责测试被俘者的性病和处女情况，被宣布为纯洁的人能卖出更高的价格。拍卖在欧洲进行，但受害者可以被运送到世界任何地方的出价最高者手中，心仪特定女性的客户也可以支付巨额费用。
cost to have the Black Death group kidnap targets that fulfilled their individual requirements. Black Death's notoriety was well-established, but also dubious. In July 2015, two years before the group claimed to have kidnapped Chloe Ailing, journalist Joseph Cox wrote an article for Tech magazine Motherboard detailing his encounter with Black Death. Upon gaining access to the site, he came across an auction for a woman named Nicole with a starting bid of $150,000. The auction advertisement was accompanied by an image of a blonde, topless woman with
让黑死病集团绑架满足其个性化要求的特定目标。黑死病的臭名昭著是众所周知的，但也存在疑点。2015年7月，在该组织声称绑架克洛伊·艾林两年前，记者约瑟夫·考克斯（Joseph Cox）为《Motherboard》科技杂志撰写了一篇文章，详细描述了他与黑死病的遭遇。在获得网站访问权限后，他偶然看到了一场针对一名叫妮可（Nicole）的女性的拍卖，起拍价为15万美元。拍卖广告配有一张金发半裸女性的照片。
her hands tied behind her back, thrashing around as the shadow of a man loomed in the background. Joseph Cox attempted to infiltrate the site by pretending to be a cryptocurrency rich customer, but was unsuccessful in gaining entry to an auction. It was later determined that the images of Nicole were screenshots taken from an unrelated pornography video, raising doubts over the legitimacy of that particular auction. A year later, in May 2016, UK authorities were alerted to a fully booked online auction taking place on the Black Death group's website, where a 15-year-old girl named Laura was on
她的双手被反绑在身后，在背景中一个男人的身影隐现的同时挣扎着。约瑟夫·考克斯试图冒充加密货币富豪客户潜入该网站，但未能成功进入拍卖会。后来确定，妮可的照片是从无关的色情视频中截取的截图，这引发了对该特定拍卖合法性的怀疑。一年后的2016年5月，英国当局接到警报，称黑死病集团网站上正在进行一场预订满额的在线拍卖，其中一名叫劳拉（Laura）的15岁女孩正在被。
sale for £575,000, and a 17-year-old girl identified as Gemma was on sale for £92,000. Investigators were unable to determine whether these auctions were real, or if the sales ever went ahead. A year passed before the next Black Death auction was scheduled for Sunday, July 16, 2017, this time advertising the sale of 20-year-old Chloe Aileen. Despite the email from the Black Death group warning him not to notify the police, Phil Green contacted law enforcement in Milan to alert them of Chloe's abduction. Local police wanted him to make a missing person's report in person, but as this was
以575,000英镑的价格出售，另一名被识别为杰玛（Gemma）的17岁女孩以92,000英镑的价格出售。调查人员无法确定这些拍卖是真是假，或者这些交易是否真的进行了。一年过去了，下一次黑死病拍卖定于2017年7月16日星期日举行，这次宣传的是20岁克洛伊·艾林的出售。尽管黑死病集团发邮件警告他不要报警，但菲尔·格林还是联系了米兰的执法部门，向他们通报了克洛伊被绑架的情况。当地警方希望他亲自去报失踪，但由于这并不实际。
not practical, Phil reached out to the British Consulate Office in Milan for help, who expedited an investigation. An alarm police arrived to Andre Lazio's photography studio, and upon gaining access to the building, discovered that it was empty inside, and there was nothing to suggest that it had ever been used for such a purpose. Temporary walls had been set up to create a makeshift corridor from the front door to the back of the building. Police found an abandoned suitcase by the door, and further inside, they came across
菲尔向英国驻米兰领事馆寻求帮助，后者加快了调查进度。大批警察抵达安德烈·拉蒂奥的摄影工作室，在进入大楼后，发现里面空无一物，没有任何迹象表明这里曾被用于此类用途。临时墙壁被搭建起来，形成了一条从前门通往建筑后部的简易走廊。警方在门边发现了一个被遗弃的手提箱，再往里走，他们看到了一部手机。
a mobile phone, jeans, shoes, and a pink leather jacket. Alongside the clothes, a piece of paper featured a picture of 11 men wearing long gowns and beaked masks, marked with the words, Black Death Group, Chloe. Working in conjunction with the authorities in the UK, Milan police initiated the search for Chloe and her abductors. With little to go on, a team of investigators started the arduous task of trawling through CCTV footage near Lazio's fake photography studio to see if they could piece together Chloe's final movements.
一条手机、牛仔裤、鞋子和一件粉色皮夹克。在衣服旁边，一张纸上印着11名身穿长袍、戴着鸟嘴面具的男子的图片，上面写着“黑死病集团，克洛伊”。与英国当局合作，米兰警方开始了对克洛伊及其绑架者的搜寻。由于线索寥寥，一组调查人员开始了一项艰巨的任务，即在拉蒂奥假摄影工作室附近的闭路电视监控录像中搜寻，看看是否能拼凑出克洛伊最后的行动轨迹。
Meanwhile, specialist officers in the UK covertly took over Phil Green's email account to begin negotiations with Black Death, which continued throughout the five days leading up to the auction. One email from the mysterious group read, I think I haven't been clear enough. My superiors tell me there is a high interest in Chloe for auction. Time is running out. Auction is on Sunday. I might be a contract killer, but real life isn't fucking John Wick.
与此同时，英国的特工人员秘密接管了菲尔·格林的电子邮件账户，开始与黑死病进行谈判，谈判持续了拍卖前五天的全过程。神秘集团的一封邮件写道：“我觉得我还没说明白。我的上司告诉我，大家对克洛伊拍卖的兴趣很高。时间不多了。拍卖在周日。我可能是一个合同杀手，但现实生活可不是他妈的约翰·威克。”
I will be unable to protect her if you people do nothing about it. The email contained an advertisement for the auction that was apparently being circulated on the dark web. The ad featured photographs of a seemingly unconscious pale Chloe sprawled out on the floor wearing her pink Chanel bodysuit and ankle socks, with her long blonde hair messily tassled around her and arms awkwardly bent upwards. Her eyes were open but glazed and staring off into the distance, and her pupils were noticeably dilated.
“如果你们什么都不做，我将无法保护她。”邮件中包含了一份据称正在暗网上流传的拍卖广告。广告上的照片显示，一个脸色苍白、看似失去知觉的克洛伊四肢瘫软地趴在地板上，身上穿着粉色香奈儿连体衣和短袜，她长长的金发凌乱地散落着，双臂以一种别扭的姿势向上弯曲。她的眼睛睁着，但目光呆滞，凝视着远方，她的瞳孔明显放大。
The piece of paper found at the fake photography studio with the image of the masked men in robes was laid on her stomach, reading, Black Death Group, Chloe. Believed to be a victim of human trafficking, Chloe was subject to the highest alert in Europe. Thus the date of the auction loomed, her image was distributed to police stations all over the continent, with international police organisation Interpol now involved in the investigation. Bayard Arale and Phil Green were in constant contact with the British consulate to receive updates on any developments in the case, which were limited.
在假摄影工作室发现的那张印有穿长袍戴面具男子形象的纸被放在她的肚皮上，上面写着：“黑死病集团，克洛伊”。由于被认为是人口贩卖的受害者，克洛伊在欧洲受到了最高级别的警报。随着拍卖日期的临近，她的照片被分发到欧洲大陆的各个警察局，国际刑警组织也介入了调查。巴亚达·艾林和菲尔·格林与英国领事馆保持着密切联系，以获取案件进展的任何最新消息，但进展非常有限。
Investigators had yet to find evidence indicating Chloe's whereabouts, and were so far unsuccessful in locating the invitation-only dark website where her auction was to take place. Phil had attempted to come up with the ransom, but had only managed to extract an offer of £20,000 from one of the three men on the list of names Chloe had provided to the Black Death Group. As the date of the auction came and went, the police and Chloe's loved ones waited in nervous, helpless anticipation. At 9.30 am on Monday, July 17, the day after the auction, the British consulate in Milan
调查人员尚未找到表明克洛伊下落的证据，到目前为止，在定位她将被拍卖的仅限邀请的暗网网站方面也没有成功。菲尔曾试图凑齐赎金，但从克洛伊提供给黑死病集团的名字列表中的三名男子那里，只勉强筹集到了2万英镑的报价。随着拍卖日期的到来又过去，警察和克洛伊的亲人们在紧张、无助的期盼中等待着。7月17日星期一上午9点30分，即拍卖结束的第二天，英国驻米兰领事馆。
opened its doors and a man and woman walked in together. The young blonde-haired woman was wearing a tracksuit that was too big for her petite frame and a pair of running shoes. She approached the front counter and told the receptionist that was an emergency and that she'd be seen to immediately. The couple were rushed through a metal detector and passed two armed soldiers into the office of the consulate. A translator greeted them and the young woman announced,
大门打开了，一男一女走了进来。年轻的金发女子穿着一件对她娇小的身材来说过大的运动服和一双跑鞋。她走到前台，告诉接待员这是紧急情况，需要立刻接待。两人匆忙通过金属探测器，穿过两名武装士兵进入了领事办公室。一名翻译迎上前去，年轻女子宣布：
I was kidnapped. I'm Chloe Eileen. Chloe was immediately led into a private room. When the man she was with tried to follow, a group of armed security guards gathered around him ordering him to stay put. Chloe told the consulate staff the man was a friend and that she called him after being released by her kidnappers. However, when the police arrived, they asked her to provide the phone number she had used
“我被绑架了。我是克洛伊·艾林。”克洛伊立即被带进一个私人房间。当她同行的男子试图跟进去时，一群武装保安围了上来，命令他留在原地。克洛伊告诉领事馆工作人员，这名男子是她的朋友，她在被绑架者释放后给他打了电话。然而，当警察赶到时，他们要求她提供用来给这位所谓的朋友打电话的电话号码，她却拿不出来。
to call this supposed friend and she was unable to. Caught in her lie, Chloe panicked, telling the police that although she was now free, she was still under the clutches of the Black Death Group. Chloe relayed her ordeal to police, starting her story six days earlier on Tuesday, July 11, the day of the photo shoot. After departing her hotel, she took a taxi to André Lartier's studio. A prominent number seven to the right of the front doors indicated that Chloe was in the right place, but the building's lower floor windows were covered in bars and there was
谎言被拆穿后，克洛伊惊慌失措，告诉警察尽管她现在自由了，但她仍然在黑死病集团的魔掌之中。克洛伊向警方讲述了她的遭遇，将她的故事从六天前的7月11日星期二——也就是拍摄当天——开始讲起。离开酒店后，她乘出租车前往安德烈·拉蒂奥的工作室。正门右侧显眼的数字“7”表明克洛伊没有走错地方，但该建筑一楼的窗户上装有铁栏杆，而且没有招牌表明里面有工作室。
no signage to suggest there was a studio inside. When she tried to open the doors, they wouldn't budge. A panel of buzzers sat to the left of the door, but there was nothing to indicate which one she should press. Chloe flicked through the emails on her mobile phone until she found the number she had used to contact André Lartier months earlier when she was in Paris. She called the number and a man answered who introduced himself as Daniel, before directing Chloe to walk a little further down the road to a smaller building which looked like a
当她试图推开大门时，门纹丝不动。门左侧有一排蜂鸣器，但没有任何迹象表明她应该按哪一个。克洛伊在手机邮件里翻找，直到找到几个月前她在巴黎时用来联系安德烈·拉蒂奥的号码。她拨了这个号码，一个自称丹尼尔（Daniel）的男子接了电话，随后指导克洛伊顺着路再往前走一小段，去一座看起来像废弃店面兼车库的小建筑。
disused shopfront in a garage. As she had been on many shoots in a wide variety of locations, there was nothing about this location that set off any alarm bells for Chloe. In the modeling world, photographers often used empty shops and unrenovated warehouses as the large spaces gave them the versatility to light the shot from all angles. Chloe pushed the front door open, placing her suitcase to the side before heading down a makeshift corridor that led further in. Towards the back of the building, she found a door marked with a black sign that said
由于她曾在各种各样的地方参加过许多拍摄，这个地方并没有引起克洛伊的任何警觉。在模特界，摄影师经常使用空店铺和未经装修的仓库，因为宽敞的空间让他们能够灵活地从各个角度进行布光。克洛伊推开前门，把手提箱放在一边，然后沿着一条通往内部深处的简易走廊走去。在建筑物的后部，她发现了一扇门，上面有一个黑色的牌子，用白色字母写着。
Studio in white lettering. Unlike typical modeling shots which were a hive of activity with the bustle of the creative team and loud music playing, this building was eerily silent. As Chloe reached out to open the studio door, a gloved hand slammed over her mouth from behind and another snaked around her neck. Unable to squirm away, she watched as a second figure appeared in front of her, his face covered by a black ski mask. He pushed up the sleeve of Chloe's leather jacket and jabbed the needle point of a syringe
“Studio”（工作室）。与典型的充满创意团队喧嚣和播放着劲爆音乐、一片繁忙景象的模特拍摄现场不同，这座建筑静得诡异。正当克洛伊伸手去开工作室的门时，一只戴着手套的手从后面猛地捂住她的嘴，另一只手勒住了她的脖子。她无法挣脱，眼睁睁地看着第二个身影出现在她面前，他的脸被黑色的滑雪面罩遮住。他推起克洛伊皮夹克的袖子，将注射器的针头刺入。
into her right wrist before injecting its contents into her body. The last thing she remembered was her muscles beginning to relax, before everything went black. When Chloe awoke some time later, it was pitch dark, her wrists were handcuffed together, her feet were bound, and there was duct tape covering her mouth. She was still wearing her body suit and socks, but everything else was gone. Her heart was beating abnormally fast and she was only able to take short, shallow breaths through her nose.
扎进她的右腕，然后将里面的液体注射进她体内。她记起的最后的事情是她的肌肉开始放松，随后一切都陷入了黑暗。当克洛伊一段时间后醒来时，四周一片漆黑，她的手腕被手铐铐在一起，双脚被绑着，嘴上贴着宽胶带。她身上还穿着连体衣和袜子，但其他一切都没了。她的心脏跳动异常快，只能通过鼻子进行短促而浅的呼吸。
She could feel movement beneath her, but was completely confined in a hot, compact space that limited her to the fetal position. She soon realised she was inside a bag. Chloe was able to manoeuvre her hands to peel the tape off her mouth and began wiggling her finger against the zip of the bag, eventually opening a small gap that allowed some air in. As her groggyness subsided, she realised she was in the boot of a moving vehicle and screamed for the driver to stop.
她能感觉到身下的晃动，但被完全禁锢在一个炎热、狭窄的空间里，只能蜷缩成胎儿的姿势。她很快意识到自己在包里。克洛伊设法挪动双手把嘴上的胶带撕了下来，并开始用手指去拨拉包的拉链，最终拉开了一个小缝，让一些空气透了进来。随着头晕目眩的感觉消退，她意识到自己在行驶中的汽车后备箱里，并尖叫着让司机停车。
She worked the zip open until she could get her cuffed hands out and began hitting them against the underside of the parcel shelf above, which dislodged and came tumbling down on top of her. The vehicle immediately swerved and came to a stop. Chloe heard its doors open before the lid of the boot launched upwards and she saw two men wearing black ski masks looking down at her. Without a word, they replaced the tape over her mouth and to zip the bag up again. They drove for what felt to Chloe like ours, only stopping occasionally so her captors
她拉开拉链，直到能把戴着手铐的双手伸出来，并开始用手敲击上方行李架的底部，行李架随即脱落并砸到了她身上。汽车立刻猛打方向盘停了下来。克洛伊听到车门打开的声音，随后后备箱盖向上弹起，她看到两个戴着黑色滑雪面罩的男人正低头看着她。他们一言不发地重新用胶带封住她的嘴，再次拉上了包的拉链。车子行驶了对克洛伊来说漫长得像几个小时的路程，其间只是偶尔停下来，以便绑架者。
could give her sips of water and replace the tape over her mouth, which had a hard time sticking against her sweaty skin. When the car stopped for a third time, an unfamiliar, unmasked man climbed into the boot and started spooning her. Chloe considered whether his lack of disguise meant she was not expected to get out alive to identify him and took the opportunity to bombard him with questions about her predicament. He spoke with an accent in broken English, never raising his voice above a whisper, telling her that she had been kidnapped by two Romanian men who had now passed her under him and the
可以喂她几口水，并重新把胶带贴在她的嘴上，因为胶带很难粘在她出汗的皮肤上。当汽车第三次停下时，一个陌生的、未戴面罩的男子爬进后备箱，从背后抱住了她（像勺子一样依偎着她）。克洛伊考虑着他没有伪装是否意味着她不会被活着放出去指认他，并抓住机会抛出一连串关于她困境的问题。他带着口音说英语，而且说得磕磕绊绊，声音始终没有超过耳语，告诉她她被两个罗马尼亚人绑架了，他们现在把她转交给了他和。
driver of the car. He answered her many questions with the same response. I don't know. Helplessness washed over Chloe and she started to cry. The man tried to calm her nerves by promising they would not harm her and she felt somewhat soothed by his soft voice and kind manner. He gently pulled her bodysuit straight without any unnecessary touching to prevent her breasts from being exposed, which reassured Chloe that he did not intend to sexually assault
汽车司机。他用同样的回答回应了她提出的许多问题：“我不知道。”无助感涌上心头，克洛伊哭了起来。那名男子承诺不会伤害她，以此来安抚她紧张的神经，她被他柔和的声音和友善的态度所抚慰，心情稍微平复了一些。他轻轻地拉直了她的连体衣，没有任何不必要的触摸以防止她的胸部暴露，这让克洛伊确信他无意性侵。
her. The pair remained in the hot, stuffy boot together for the remainder of the journey, during which the man agreed to unlock Chloe's handcuffs to provide her momentary relief but replaced them as soon as the car reached its final destination. Chloe was zipped back up into the oversized duffel bag, with her two captors threatening to inject her with a sedative again if she didn't cooperate. Terrified at the thought of the syringe, she complied, remaining still so they could carry her up what felt like a steep hill.
两人一起挤在炎热、闷热的后备箱里度过了旅程的剩余部分，其间那名男子同意解开克洛伊的手铐以给她短暂的解脱，但一到汽车的最终目的地就重新给她戴上了。克洛伊被重新拉上拉链装进那个特大的行李袋里，她的两个绑架者威胁说，如果她不配合，就再次给她注射镇静剂。一想到注射器她就感到恐惧，于是她顺从了，一动不动地任由他们把她抬上了一条感觉像是陡峭山路的地方。
She heard the sound of a door unlocking and they gently placed her down and unzipped the bag. Once her eyes adjusted, Chloe realized she was in a cramped and cluttered kitchen. The man who had spent the final leg of the car ride in the boot with her remained unmasked while his cohort wore a balaclava. Chloe asked to use the toilet and was directed up a flight of bare concrete stairs with a wall to the left and no banister. The men followed her to the shabby bathroom and ordered her to leave the door open.
她听到门锁被打开的声音，他们轻轻地把她放下并拉开了包的拉链。等眼睛适应后，克洛伊发现自己在一间狭窄凌乱的厨房里。在后备箱里陪了她最后一程的那个男子依然没有戴面罩，而他的同伙则戴着巴拉克拉瓦头套。克洛伊要求上厕所，被指引着走上一段光秃秃的混凝土楼梯，左边是一堵墙，没有扶手。两个男人跟着她来到简陋的浴室，命令她把门开着。
Once she was finished, the men led Chloe through a beaded curtain to a small room that was painted yellow-green. Her chest of wooden drawers took up the length of one wall and a sleeping bag was positioned on the floor next to it. A single bed sat on the other side with a multicolored crocheted blanket pulled neatly across it. The masked man pointed at the sleeping bag, indicating for Chloe to lie on it. Her hands and feet were then handcuffed to the legs of the chest of drawers.
完事后，男人们带着克洛伊穿过一扇串珠门帘，来到一个小房间，房间刷着黄绿色。一面墙的长度摆放着一个木制抽屉柜，旁边地板上放着一个睡袋。另一边放着一张单人床，上面整齐地拉着一条色彩斑斓的钩针编织毯子。戴面罩的男人指着睡袋，示意克洛伊躺上去。接着，她的手和脚被铐在了抽屉柜的腿上。
Satisfied that she wasn't going anywhere, her captors went back downstairs where she could hear them speaking in a foreign language. After some time, the unmasked man returned. Still speaking in his quiet, soothing voice, he told Chloe that he's part of the job was complete and it was time for him to leave. But something had gone wrong and his angry boss was now on the way to see her. He assured her that once the boss arrived she would be told what was going on. Chloe remained on the floor, her ability to move limited by the awkward position she had
确信她哪儿也去不了后，绑架者回到楼下，她能听到他们在用一门外语交谈。过了一会儿，没戴面罩的男子回来了。他依然用他那安静、舒缓的声音告诉克洛伊，他那部分的工作已经完成，是时候离开了。但出了点问题，他愤怒的老板现在正赶来见她。他向她保证，一旦老板到达，就会有人告诉她发生了什么事。克洛伊留在地板上，由于被铐住的姿势十分别扭，她的行动能力受到了限制。
been handcuffed in. She heard a commotion downstairs with men yelling and a door slamming, followed by a one-sided heated conversation which she assumed was conducted on the telephone. Before long, another man entered the room and released the handcuffs around Chloe's wrist, leaving her shackled by the ankle. The man sat on the single bed and Chloe twisted around so that she could see him. She didn't immediately recognise the skinny, brown-haired, clean-shaven man, but didn't find him particularly daunting either.
她听到楼下一阵骚动，伴随着男人的叫喊声和关门声，接着是一场单方面的激烈谈话，她猜测那是通过电话进行的。没过多久，另一个男人走进房间，解开了克洛伊手腕上的手铐，只留下脚踝上的镣铐。那名男子坐在单人床边，克洛伊转过身去看着他。她没有立刻认出那个瘦削、棕发、刮得光溜溜的男子，但也并没有觉得他特别吓人。
He calmly told her, I don't know if you remember, but I briefly met you in Paris. It then clipped to Chloe. Although he was wearing sunglasses during their first meeting, the man sitting before her was Andre Lazio, the head photographer for the motorcycle photo shoot. He revealed that his name was not Andre Lazio, nor was he a photographer, reintroducing himself as MD. He claimed that the Romanians who had kidnapped Chloe and to the pair who had driven her to the remote house all worked for the same organisation as he did.
他平静地告诉她，不知道你还记不记得，我们在巴黎短暂见过面。镜头随即切换到克洛伊。虽然第一次见面时他戴着墨镜，但坐在她面前的这个男人正是安德烈·拉齐奥，那场摩托车写真拍摄的首席摄影师。他透露，他的名字不叫安德烈·拉齐奥，也不是什么摄影师，并重新自我介绍说自己叫MD。他声称，绑架克洛伊的罗马尼亚人以及开车送她到偏僻房屋的那两个人，都和他效力于同一个组织。
The Black Death Group According to MD, the Black Death Group was the largest mafia-style organisation in the world, with members positioned throughout a 20-level hierarchy. MD was at level 12 and operated as an assassin for the organisation, with poisoning being his preferred method of murder. The other men involved in Chloe's abduction were low-level foot soldiers who had drugged her before strip-searching her for tracking devices. He explained the purpose of Chloe's abduction was to sell her on the dark web, with her
黑死神集团。据MD交代，黑死神集团是世界上最大的黑帮性质组织，成员分布在20个层级的等级制度中。MD处于第12层，在组织里担任刺客，投毒是他最擅长的谋杀手法。参与绑架克洛伊的其他男子都是低阶步兵，他们在给克洛伊下药后，脱光了她的衣服搜查追踪设备。他解释说，绑架克洛伊的目的是在暗网上出售她，
auction scheduled to take place in five days' time. It was not the first time Black Death had carried out such an auction. MD explained that the group usually snatched three to four girls a week from bars or nightclubs, bringing them to their remote property where they were kept in a shed and chained to the rafters. Once the girls were sold, they were used as sex slaves and passed around to other men in the buyer's family before being fed to pet tigers when the owners grew bored of her. To prove his claims, MD took out his laptop and showed Chloe the advertisement for her
拍卖定在五天后举行。这已经不是黑死神第一次进行这样的拍卖了。MD解释说，该组织通常每周从酒吧或夜总会绑架三到四个女孩，把她们带到偏僻的房产里，关在棚子里，并用铁链锁在椽子上。一旦女孩被卖掉，她们就会沦为性奴，在买家家族的其他男人之间轮流转手，等主人玩腻了，就会被拿去喂宠物老虎。为了证明自己所言非虚，MD拿出了笔记本电脑，向克洛伊展示了她的
sale. Her featured a photograph of her she didn't recall having taken, where she was sprawled out on the floor in her pink bodysuit, along with a link to her Instagram profile and a description that read, Chloe, born in UK, abducted in Italy, held in Germany, 19 years old, Caucasian, 34 double D, 25, 35, beginner model. Starting bid, 300,000 euros. Auction takes place, 16 July, 2017.
出售广告。上面有一张她自己都不记得什么时候拍的照片：她穿着粉色紧身衣四脚朝天趴在地板上，旁边还有通往她Instagram个人主页的链接以及一段文字描述：克洛伊，生于英国，在意大利被绑架，关押在德国，19岁，高加索人，34DD胸围，腰围25，臀围35，初级模特。起拍价30万欧元。拍卖时间：2017年7月16日。
MD revealed that very powerful men in the Middle East were showing a lot of interest in her auction, but a problem had since arisen in Black Death's plans and his superiors were not happy. He scrolled through their website to the list of rules governing Black Death's auctions and pointed to one that read, We do not sell girls that are terminally ill, pregnant, have STDs, or are young mothers. The group had failed to realise that Chloe was the mother of a two-year-old son, having fallen pregnant at the age of 17.
MD透露，中东地区的几位权势人物对她的拍卖表现出了极大的兴趣，但黑死神集团的计划随后出现了问题，他的上司们很不高兴。他在网站上翻到了规范黑死神拍卖规则的页面，指着其中一条念道：我们不出售身患绝症、怀孕、患有性病或身为年轻母亲的女孩。该组织先前并不知道克洛伊是一个两岁男孩的母亲，她在17岁时就怀孕了。
She had long since split with her son's father and the estranged couple shared custody of the young boy. Under the Black Death group's own rules, Chloe Ailing could not be sold. MD only found out Chloe had a son after seeing pictures of him on her Instagram page, forcing him to cancel her abduction, which was originally intended to take place during her trip to Paris in April. However, the lesser-ranking Black Death members had misunderstood the change of plans and continued emailing Phil Green using the André Lartier alias to reschedule the fake photo
她和孩子的父亲早已分手，两人共同抚养这个小男孩。根据黑死神集团自身的规则，克洛伊·艾灵是不能被出售的。MD是在克洛伊的Instagram主页上看到她儿子的照片后才发现这一点的，这迫使他取消了原本计划在4月巴黎之行期间实施的绑架。然而，黑死神集团里那些地位较低的成员误解了计划的变更，继续使用安德烈·拉蒂耶的化名给菲尔·格林发电子邮件，重新安排在米兰拍摄假写真，
shoot in Milan to carry out the crime there instead. As she had already been advertised for sale and to the Black Death group didn't want to upset their wealthy clients, MD stated that the only way to secure Chloe's freedom was for her to come up with her own starting bid of €300,000. This wasn't particularly reassuring to Chloe as she didn't have access to such funds, but MD said he would do whatever he could to help her out. He told her to come up with the names of three people who would be willing and able to provide the money to secure her release.
以此在那里实施犯罪。由于克洛伊已经被挂网叫卖，且黑死神集团不想惹恼他们富有的客户，MD表示，要想确保克洛伊重获自由，唯一的办法就是让她自己筹集30万欧元的起拍价。这并没有让克洛伊感到多少宽慰，因为她根本接触不到这么大一笔资金，但MD表示他会尽其所能帮助她。他让她说出三个愿意并且有能力提供这笔资金以确保她获释的人的名字。
Chloe gave him the names of three well-off associates, Rory, an investment banker she had recently dated, and two supermodel agency clients, one who managed public relations for 66 magazine and one who owned Men's Lifestyle magazine, Loaded. MD explained he would email the names to Phil Green and tell him he had until Saturday to get the money together, otherwise Chloe's auction would go live on Sunday. Although being a mother had significantly decreased Chloe's value, MD was confident there would still be interest in her sale. Chloe spent her first night in captivity lying on the floor on top of the sleeping bag, cuffed
克洛伊说出了三个富裕熟人的名字：罗里，一个她最近约会过的投资银行家，以及两个超级名模经纪公司的客户，其中一位是《66》杂志的公关负责人，另一位是《Loaded》男性时尚杂志的老板。MD解释说，他会将这些名字通过电子邮件发给菲尔·格林，并告诉对方，他必须在周六前筹集到资金，否则克洛伊的拍卖将在周日上线。尽管身为母亲大幅降低了克洛伊的价值，但MD坚信她的拍卖依然会吸引人。克洛伊在 captivity（被囚禁）的第一夜是躺在地板上的睡袋里度过的，她的手腕和脚踝
by her wrists and ankles to the chest of drawers. MD came in and out of the room throughout the night, sitting on the single bed beside her and rambling on about Black Death, his important role within the organization and the risks he was willing to take to help her. He even offered to pay part of the release money himself, provided Chloe was able to raise the bulk of it. He told Chloe she was no longer in Italy and was being held elsewhere on a remote property owned by MD that was isolated enough that nobody would be able to hear her scream.
被手铐铐在五斗橱上。整夜，MD不断进出房间，坐在她身边的单人床上，喋喋不休地谈论着黑死神、他在组织里的重要角色，以及他为了帮助她愿意冒的风险。他甚至主动提出自己支付一部分赎金，前提是克洛伊能够筹集到大部分资金。他告诉克洛伊，她已经不在意大利了，而是被关在MD名下一处偏僻的房产里，那里极其偏僻，没有任何人能听到她的尖叫。
He threatened that she would be hunted down and killed if she tried to escape, but maintained that she was safe in his presence, as the penalty for any Black Death operative who messed with the merchandise was death. MD brought her food, but as he had already informed her that he carried out assassinations by poisoning his victims, she refused to eat it. As the second day wore on, Chloe was informed that Phil Green had responded to the ransom email with a single word and nothing else. That afternoon, MD offered that she share the double bed in the next room with him.
他威胁说，如果她试图逃跑，就会遭到追杀并被杀死；但他坚称，只要有他在，她就是安全的，因为任何敢动“货物”的黑死神特工都将被处以死刑。MD给她带了食物，但由于他之前已经告诉过她，他通过向受害者投毒来实施暗杀，因此她拒绝吃那些食物。随着第二天过去，克洛伊得知菲尔·格林对勒索邮件只回复了一个词，别的什么都没说。那天下午，MD提出让她和自己合住隔壁房间的双人床。
Comforted by the fact that MD would be killed if he did anything to harm her, Chloe opted to sleep in the bed, and the two slept back to back under separate blankets. From then on, Chloe was allowed to remain in the bed, leaving only to go to the bathroom. MD strictly warned that she was not allowed to go downstairs or attempt to look through the shuttered windows. MD left the house frequently, telling Chloe he was driving to get reception on his phone so that he could check on the status of her ransom payment. She obeyed all his orders while he was gone, fearful there were cameras in the house or
由于得知如果MD做任何伤害她的事就会被处死，这一事实给了她一丝安慰，克洛伊选择睡在那张床上，两人盖着各自的毯子背靠背睡着了。从那时起，克洛伊被允许留在床上，只有去洗手间时才可以离开。MD严厉警告她，绝对不准下楼，也不准试图透过百叶窗往外看。MD经常离开房子，告诉克洛伊他是开车去搜寻手机信号，以便查看她赎金支付的进展情况。他在离开时，她服从了他所有的命令，因为她害怕房子里装有摄像头，或者
that other people nearby were keeping an eye on her. MD would return frustrated with the lack of progress obtaining the ransom money, telling Chloe that if they didn't get the payment soon, there was no choice but to prepare for her auction. This required more photographs to be taken for her bidders and a visit from a doctor to check her for sexually transmitted diseases and pregnancy. By the third day of Chloe's captivity, MD began opening up about his earlier life in the military and how he came to be an assassin.
附近有其他人一直在监视她。MD每次回来都会因为筹集赎金进展缓慢而感到沮丧，他告诉克洛伊，如果他们不能尽快收到款项，就别无选择，只能为她的拍卖做准备。这就需要为竞拍者拍摄更多的照片，并安排医生来检查她是否患有性病和怀孕。在克洛伊被囚禁的第三天，MD开始向她敞开心扉，讲述自己早年在军队的经历以及他是如何成为一名刺客的。
When he boasted that he had earned $15 million from his work in the Black Death Group, Chloe realized he was trying to impress her. As she was no stranger to men's affection and flirting was part of her job when attending events and working as a hostess, Chloe saw this as a chance at survival. She responded with warmth and affection, encouraging him to talk more and more. MD confessed he wanted to break free of the Black Death Group, but doing so would require him to pay $1.5 million and transfer all 20 of his properties to the organization. When they weren't talking, MD and Chloe played hangman and battleship to pass the time.
当他吹嘘自己通过在黑死神集团的工作赚了1500万美元时，克洛伊意识到他是在试图向自己炫耀。由于她对男人的追求并不陌生，而且出席活动和担任礼宾员时调情本来就是她工作的一部分，克洛伊将这视为一次求生的机会。她热情而深情地回应了他，鼓励他说得越来越多。MD坦白说，他想脱离黑死神集团，但这样做需要他支付150万美元，并将其所有的20处房产全部转让给该组织。在不谈这些的时候，MD和克洛伊会玩绞刑架猜词和海战棋来打发时间。
She's demeanor softened and he became less formal, with Chloe sensing she was no longer just a business transaction to him. Famished and to no longer fearful he was trying to poison her, she accepted a chocolate bar from him. Although furious inside, she remained poised and tried to humanize herself further by talking about how much she missed her mother and son. The more the pair spoke, the more it felt like MD believed a bond was forming between them and Chloe used this to her advantage.
她的态度软化了，他的语气也不那么正式了，克洛伊感觉到自己在对方眼里不再只是一笔生意。她饿得慌，也不再害怕他试图下毒，便接受了他给的一块巧克力。虽然内心愤怒，但她保持着镇定，并通过谈论自己多么想念母亲和儿子，进一步展现自己人性化的一面。两人聊得越多，越让MD觉得他们之间正在建立一种纽带，而克洛伊则利用了这一点来为自己谋取利益。
By Friday morning, four days into Chloe's captivity and two days before her scheduled auction, MD asked if they could share a kiss. Chloe told him it would only be possible once she was free, prompting MD to start brainstorming ideas about how they could secure her safe release if they couldn't come up with the ransom money in time. As the Black Death Group didn't have a strong presence in London, he suggested she agreed to promote the group in the UK in exchange for her freedom. MD took his plan to the higher-ranking members of the organization, later informing Chloe that
到了周五早上，也就是克洛伊被囚禁的第四天，距离她预定的拍卖还有两天，MD问他们能不能接个吻。克洛伊告诉他，只有当她重获自由后才有可能，这促使MD开始集思广益，盘算着如果他们无法及时筹集到赎金，该如何确保她安全获释。由于黑死神集团在伦敦没有很强的势力，他建议她答应在英国为该组织宣传，以此换取自由。MD将他的计划带给了该组织的高层成员，随后通知克洛伊说
they had struck a deal. He handed her a letter, which read, You are being released as a huge generosity from Black Death Group. Your release does, however, come with a warning, and you should read this letter carefully. Chloe was given strict instructions that upon her return to London, she was not allowed to pursue any investigation into her kidnapping. She was also required to pay 50,000 euros in cryptocurrency to the Black Death Group and promote them by, quote,
他们已经达成了一笔交易。他递给她一封信，上面写着：鉴于黑死神集团的极度慷慨，你现在获释了。然而，你的获释伴随着警告，你应该仔细阅读这信。克洛伊得到了严格的指示：在她返回伦敦后，不得对自己的绑架事件进行任何追查。她还必须向黑死神集团支付5万欧元的加密货币，并通过以下方式为他们进行宣传，原文为：
sneaking a predetermined set of information into the media. The letter went on to say, You and your family will in no way ever talk about us in bad language and without respect. You have been treated fairly, with respect, and we expect to hear exactly the same about us in return. Any sort of disobedience with the above will result in your elimination. Following her release from the Black Death Group on Monday, July 17, Chloe Ailing was transported to the Milan police station where she was formally questioned about every detail
“将一套预先设定好的信息悄悄塞进媒体中。”信中接着写道：你和你的家人绝不能以恶劣的语言和不尊重的方式谈论我们。你受到了公平、有尊严的对待，我们希望得到完全相同的回报。任何不服从上述规定的行为都将导致你的消亡。在7月17日星期一从黑死神集团获释后，克洛伊·艾灵被送往米兰警察局，在那里她就绑架和囚禁的每一个细节接受了正式盘问。
of her abduction and captivity. Everything she said was recorded, analyzed, queried, and clarified, which was a time-consuming process requiring the help of a translator. She was also subjected to a thorough medical examination. Forensic testing revealed there was no trace of drugs in her urine, indicating she had not had any within the previous couple of days. But a hair sample came back positive for ketamine, a horse tranquilizer notoriously used as an incapacitating agent in date rape incidents.
她所说的一切都被记录、分析、质询和澄清，这是一个耗时的过程，需要翻译的协助。她还接受了全面的体检。法医检测显示她的尿液中没有任何药物痕迹，这表明她在过去几天里没有服用过任何药物。但头发样本呈氯胺酮（俗称K粉，一种常在约会强奸事件中用作迷晕剂的兽用镇静剂）阳性。
A pinhole-sized puncture mark on her wrist was evidence of a syringe wound, and the bruises around her wrists and ankles were consistent with having been handcuffed for an extended period. As she was being questioned, officers had been following up all of her claims and had figured out the location where she had been held captive, finding her DNA on the handcuffs, floor, and bed. M.D. had lied to Chloe about crossing the Italian border. The run-down farmhouse she had been taken to was located in a tiny hamlet of derelict
她手腕上针孔大小的刺痕是注射器注射的证据，手腕和脚踝周围的瘀伤也与被长时间戴手铐的情况相符。在她接受盘问的同时，警官们一直在跟进她的所有陈述，并找到了她被关押的地点，在手铐、地板和床上都发现了她的DNA。M.D.对克洛伊撒了谎，说他们越过了意大利边境。她被带去的那座破败农舍位于意大利北部小村庄拉姆涅尔（L'Amnière）附近的一个荒废房屋小村落里，距离都灵市西北35公里。
houses near the small northern Italian village of L'Amnière, 35km northwest of the city of Turin. M.D. did not own the property, as he said, but had rented it for a 20-day period over the time of her imprisonment. The closest place to buy food and supplies was a 15-minute drive away in VU, a picturesque alpine town with a grocery store, cafes, and shops. Although VU was busy during the snow season, it was quiet during the summer, and strangers in the town stood out.
M.D.并没有拥有这处房产，正如他所说的那样，而是租用了20天，正好涵盖她被囚禁的时间。买食物和日用品最近的地方在15分钟车程之外的VU，那是一个风景如画的高山小镇，有杂货店、咖啡馆和商店。虽然VU在雪季时很热闹，但夏天时却很安静，镇上的陌生人格外显眼。
Local traders were shown photographs of Chloe and her male consulate companion, and several recognized M.D. right away. He had visited the town to dine at the local pizza restaurant nearly every day of Chloe's captivity, with the owner of the minimart telling police that he had been into the store three or four times to purchase groceries. On the morning of Chloe's auction, witnesses saw him at the minimart again, but this time he was in the company of a blonde-haired woman. The pair appeared to be a couple, holding hands and wearing matching outfits consisting
当地的商贩们看到了克洛伊和她男性同伴的照片，有几个人一眼就认出了M.D.在克洛伊被囚禁的几乎每一天，他都曾到镇上的那家比萨餐厅吃饭，便利店的老板也告诉警方，他曾三四次进店购买杂货。在克洛伊拍卖的那天早上，目击者再次在便利店看到了他，但这一次陪伴他的是一位金发女郎。两人看起来像是一对情侣，手牵着手，穿着款式相同的服装，包括
of tracksuit pants and white t-shirts. The woman, who was positively identified as Chloe Ailing, had been left standing outside the store while M.D. went in to buy fruit. The pair were also seen shopping in a shoe store, where M.D. purchased Chloe a pair of running shoes that cost around 40 euros. CCTV footage collected from the streets of VU confirmed to these sightings, capturing Chloe and her alleged kidnapper leisurely strolling hand-in-hand in broad daylight. This evidence provided a stark contrast to the allegations made by Chloe, who told police
运动裤和白色T恤。这名被确认为克洛伊·艾灵的女子，在M.D.进店买水果时被留在了店外。两人还被目击在一家鞋店购物，M.D.在那里给克洛伊买了一双价值约40欧元的跑步鞋。从VU街头收集的监控录像证实了这些目击事件，画面捕捉到了克洛伊和她的绑架嫌疑人光天化日之下悠闲地手牵着手散步的场景。这一证据与克洛伊向警方陈述的内容形成了鲜明的对比，她曾告诉警方
she was not permitted to leave the farmhouse where she was being held. After 15 hours of interrogation, police confronted Chloe with this discrepancy, causing her to break down in tears. Chloe revealed that upon securing her release, M.D. made plans to drop her off a 20-minute walk away from the British consulate in Milan. But as her jacket, jeans and sneakers had been left in the abandoned building following her abduction, she had no clothing or shoes to facilitate the journey. She borrowed a tracksuit from M.D. and on the morning of Sunday, July 16, he decided
自己不被允许离开被关押的农舍。经过15个小时的审讯后，警方将这一矛盾之处摆在克洛伊面前，导致她崩溃大哭。克洛伊透露，在确保她获释后，M.D.曾计划将她放在距离米兰英国领事馆步行20分钟的地方。但由于她的夹克、牛仔裤和运动鞋在绑架后留在了那栋废弃建筑里，她没有衣服和鞋子来完成这段路程。她向M.D.借了一套运动服，而在7月16日星期日早上，他决定
to take her shopping for shoes. For the first time since her captivity, Chloe was allowed downstairs and out of the farmhouse. M.D. drove her to VU, asserting that Black Death operatives were everywhere, rendering Chloe too afraid to scream or ask anyone for help. As she couldn't speak Italian, she was also nervous that she wouldn't be understood even if she did manage to get someone's attention. Firmly believing that earning M.D.'s trust was her only chance of escaping, she maintained her romantic facade, holding his hand as they strolled through the village together.
带她去买鞋。自被囚禁以来，克洛伊第一次被允许下楼并离开农舍。M.D.开车带她去了VU，并坚称黑死神特工无处不在，这让克洛伊吓得不敢尖叫或向任何人求救。由于不会说意大利语，她也很担心即使自己真的引起了别人的注意也无法被人听懂。她坚信赢得M.D.的信任是她逃跑的唯一机会，于是维持着浪漫的表象，在他们一起漫步村庄时紧紧拉着他的手。
The visit to the shoe shop was brief. Chloe never spoke to the staff members, simply pointing to the first pair of trainers she saw and buying them in a slightly bigger size as they didn't have her own. On the way back to the car, M.D. bought some fruit from the minimart and they went back to the farmhouse for the final night before she was due to be released. The next morning, the plan to drop Chloe near the consulate was abandoned when they arrived to Milan two hours before the building was due to open. Instead, they headed to a cafe for breakfast, where M.D. advised the new plan was for Chloe
鞋店之行很短暂。克洛伊没有和店员说话，只是指了指她看到的双第一运动鞋，由于没有她的码，她买了一双稍微大一点的。在回车的路上，M.D.在便利店买了一些水果，然后他们回到了农舍，度过了她获释前的最后一晚。次日上午，当他们在大楼开门前两小时到达米兰时，将克洛伊放在领事馆附近的计划被取消了。相反，他们前往一家咖啡馆吃早餐，M.D.在那里提出了新计划，让克洛伊
to tell the consulate staff that she had escaped, borrowed a phone from a stranger, and called him to accompany her. Investigators were skeptical of Chloe's changing story and she was forced to remain in a safe house in Italy while the investigations continued. After being informed that she would not be allowed to return home until she had provided police with all the evidence they needed, she agreed to participate in video interviews over the following days, in which she escorted investigators on a tour of the locations of her kidnapping.
告诉领事馆工作人员她已经逃脱，向陌生人借了电话，并打电话让他来陪她。调查人员对克洛伊不断变化的说法持怀疑态度，在调查继续期间，她被迫留在意大利的一个安全屋里。在被告知在向警方提供所有需要的证据之前不得返回家中后，她同意在接下来的几天里参加视频采访，并在采访中带着调查人员参观了她被绑架的地点。
She was remarkably calm as she pulled on blue latex gloves and took the police to Andrei Lazio's phony photography studio, the ramshackle two-story farmhouse, and the shops in nearby VU where they had purchased their shoes. At the farmhouse, she broke down upon discovering the property was not as remote as she was led to believe, with occupied houses neighboring both sides, close enough that they would have likely been able to hear Chloe if she had screamed. Following herself, she took the investigators on a tour of the house, where everything, down to the colours of the bedspreads and the walls, were exactly as she had described during questioning.
她表现得异常冷静，戴上蓝色乳胶鞋带警察来到安德烈·拉齐奥的假照相馆、那栋摇摇欲坠的两层农舍，以及附近VU购买鞋子的商店。在农舍里，当发现这处房产并不像她被告知的那样偏僻时，她崩溃了，两边都有邻近的有人居住的房屋，近得如果她尖叫的话，邻居们很可能会听到。随后，她带着调查人员参观了房子，里面的每一处细节，小到床单和墙壁的颜色，都与她在审讯期间描述的完全一致。
Italian police held a press conference to provide the details of Chloe's kidnapping for ransom and to the story was quickly picked up by the British press, who ran the story alongside the raunchiest of her social media photographs. Following Chloe's high-profile identity as a glamour model, it didn't take long before the public started raising serious doubts about the veracity of her story. The press clamoured for an interview with the young model, but she continued to be held by the Italian police. M.D. had been detained for questioning, with police identifying him as a 30-year-old Polish
意大利警方举行了新闻发布会，公布了克洛伊被勒索绑架的细节，这个故事很快就被英国媒体炒作起来，媒体将这起事件与她那些最火辣的社交媒体照片一起刊登出来。随着克洛伊迷人模特的身份受到高度关注，公众很快就开始对她故事的真实性产生严重怀疑。媒体争相采访这位年轻模特，但她仍被意大利警方扣留。M.D.已被扣留接受盘问，警方查明他是一名30岁的波兰
national whose real name was Wukasz Herber. Wukasz possessed a false ID issued in the name he had used to rent the false photography studio for the fabricated Andre Lattio. He also carried a business card that listed his business name as Permanent Solution, featuring a logo of the grim reaper on one side and a complicated dark web email address for M.D. on the other. Wukasz initially stuck to the story that he was a friend of Chloe's, but police remained unconvinced.
公民，真名叫武卡什·赫贝尔（Łukasz Herber）。武卡什持有假身份证，名字就是他用来为虚构的安德烈·拉蒂奥租用假照相馆时用的那个。他身上还带着一张名片，上面列出的公司名称是“永久解决方案”（Permanent Solution），一面印有死神标志，另一面印有M.D.复杂的暗网电子邮箱地址。武卡什起初坚称自己是克洛伊的朋友，但警方并不相信。
He eventually confessed to participating in the plot to kidnap her, declaring the abduction had been orchestrated by a group of Romanians who lived near his flat. They forced him under duress and paid him £500,000 for his role, which was limited to renting the fake studio and farmhouse. He made no mention of the Black Death Group, justifying that he had only agreed to participate in the crime because he was undergoing treatment for leukemia and needed money for the medical care. However, he was unable to provide any proof that he had been diagnosed with the life-threatening
他最终承认参与了绑架她的阴谋，声称绑架是由居住在他公寓附近的一群罗马尼亚人策划的。他们胁迫了他，并为他支付了5万英镑作为他参与其中的报酬，他的工作仅限于租用假照相馆和农舍。他没有提及黑死神集团，辩称自己之所以同意参与这起犯罪，是因为他正在接受白血病治疗，需要钱来支付医疗费用。然而，他无法提供任何证据证明自己被诊断出患有这种危及生命的
cancer or was undergoing any treatment and was subsequently placed under arrest for his participation in the kidnapping of Chloe Eileen. During his time in police custody, Wukasz Herber was badly beaten by other inmates after they heard he was involved in a violent crime against a woman. News of the attack reached Chloe Eileen, who felt a mix of sympathy and fear, wondering who would protect her from the Black Death Group now that Wukasz was in prison. The answer came later that week when police advised Chloe that the Black Death Group did not exist.
癌症或正在接受任何治疗，随后因参与绑架克洛伊·艾灵而被捕。在被警方羁押期间，武卡什·赫贝尔在听说他参与了一起针对女性的暴力犯罪后，遭到同押犯人的严重殴打。袭击的消息传到了克洛伊·艾灵耳中，她心中交织着同情与恐惧，心想既然武卡什已经入狱，现在还有谁能保护她免受黑死神集团的侵害。答案在当周晚些时候揭晓，当时警方通知克洛伊，黑死神集团根本不存在。
In fact, they suspected there were only two people involved in her abduction, Wukasz and his older brother, 36-year-old Mihao Herber. Evidence indicated the Herber brothers had been solely responsible for the crime. Wukasz was the silent masked man who later revealed himself as MD and hair samples found in the boot of the vehicle Chloe had been transported in confirmed it was Mihao who climbed in the car boot with her following her abduction. Wukasz had told Chloe that he had never been to England, when in reality he lived there in a council-owned flat in the western Midland city of Oldbury.
事实上，他们怀疑参与她绑架案的只有两个人：武卡什和他36岁的哥哥米豪·赫贝尔（Michał Herber）。证据表明，赫贝尔兄弟是这起犯罪的唯一幕后黑手。武卡什就是那个后来表明自己身份是MD的蒙面无声男子，而在克洛伊被运送时所乘车辆的后备箱中发现的头发样本证实，绑架发生后，是米豪跟着钻进了车里的后备箱。武卡什曾告诉克洛伊他从未去过英国，但现实中他就住在西米德兰兹郡奥尔德伯里市（Oldbury）的一处市政公寓里。
He had become obsessed with Chloe over the past two years, admiring her from afar through social media. Police believed Wukasz had kidnapped Chloe in the hopes of obtaining a ransom payout and that by posing as her saviour she would enter into a relationship with him. There was no evidence to indicate the auction was anything but a fictional tale woven by Wukasz to fool both Chloe and her agent, Phil Green. The Herber brothers' involvement came as a shock to those who knew them in their native home of Poland where they were known as polite, bright, kind and hard-working.
在过去两年里，他一直对克洛伊着迷，通过社交媒体从远处默默崇拜着她。警方认为，武卡什绑架克洛伊是希望能获得一笔赎金，并且通过伪装成她的拯救者，让她与自己谈恋爱。没有任何证据表明那场拍卖会是真实的，那不过是武卡什为了愚弄克洛伊和她的经纪人菲尔·格林而编造的谎言。赫贝尔兄弟的涉案让那些在他们老家波兰认识他们的人感到震惊，在老家，他们一直被认为是礼貌、聪明、善良且勤奋的人。
Their neighbours in the UK had other opinions regarding Wukasz in particular as a strange loner who walked around with a pet rat on his shoulder and was obsessed with computer games. One of Wukasz's former girlfriends described him as a Walter Mitty type character who lived in a fantasy world and lived to impress others. She said he was selfish and narcissistic, presenting himself as too good to be true. He'd drive around in a luxury Mercedes whilst wearing a pinstripe suit, fabricating lies that he owned land overseas, was involved in the gold trade, was a crack shot with a sniper rifle and ran a successful international firm making synthetic chicken feed.
他们在英国的邻居对武卡什有着不同的看法，认为他是个怪异的独行侠，肩膀上总是盘着一只宠物老鼠，并且痴迷于电脑游戏。武卡什的一位前女友将他描述为一个华特·米蒂式的人物，活在幻想世界里，活着就是为了给别人留下深刻印象。她说他自私且自恋，把自己包装得完美得不真实。他开着豪华梅赛德斯奔驰车兜风，穿着细条纹西装，大肆撒谎说自己在海外拥有土地，参与黄金交易，精通狙击步枪，还经营着一家生产合成鸡饲料的成功国际公司。
He also raised concerns by joking to his former girlfriend about spiking her drink with drugs. She told the Daily Mail newspaper. He seemed different to other guys, like he had class, but that is just the image he was trying to create. I was very impressed by him. He'd told me he had finished three types of business studies, had a big imagination and big plans for his business.
他还曾向前女友开玩笑说要在她的饮料里下药，这引发了对方的担忧。她告诉《每日邮报》：“他给人的感觉和其他男人不一样，好像很有品位，但这只是他刻意营造的形象。我当时对他的印象很深刻。他告诉我已经完成了三种商业研究，想象力丰富，对自己的生意有着宏大的计划。”
He told me he was going to Los Angeles for six weeks to find new contractors. In reality, Wukasz was in Milan, busy executing his plot to kidnap Chloe Eileen. During the pre-trial court proceedings, a curtain separated Chloe from the gaze of her abductor as she provided her testimony against him. When the court was satisfied, she was finally allowed to fly home to the UK, where the paparazzi were camped outside her house. After preparing a statement, her smiling Chloe greeted the press, scratching her pet dog's ears and posing for the cameras.
他告诉她自己要去洛杉矶六周以寻找新的承包商。而现实中，武卡什当时正在米兰，忙着实施他绑架克洛伊·艾灵的计划。在审前听证会上，一道帘子将克洛伊与绑架者的视线隔开，她发表了针对他的证词。当法庭感到满意时，她终于被允许飞回英国，那里有狗仔队在她的住所外安营扎寨。在准备好一份声明后，面带微笑的克洛伊向媒体打招呼，挠了挠宠物狗的耳朵，并在镜头前摆好姿势。
Her brief statement read, I've been through a terrifying experience. I feared for my life, second by second, minute by minute, hour by hour. I am incredibly grateful to the Italian and UK authorities for all they have done to secure my safe release. I have just arrived home after four weeks of being in Italy and haven't had time to gather my thoughts. I'm not at liberty to say anything further until I have been debriefed by the UK police.
她简短的声明写道：“我经历了一段可怕的经历。我每时每刻、每分每秒、每小时都在为自己的生命担忧。我非常感谢意大利和英国当局为确保我安全获释所做的一切。我在意大利待了四个星期后刚刚回到家，还没来得及整理思绪。在接受英国警方进一步盘问之前，我不便发表任何评论。”
Phil Green's phone was ringing off the hook with clients offering to pay 10 times Chloe Eileen's usual rate to book the infamous model. He phoned Chloe over and over again, but the only time her phone was answered, a man on the other end introduced himself as her new agent and unceremoniously told Phil he had been fired. Hurt and angry, Phil took his frustration to the interview circuit, claiming to have been left out of pocket for expenses related to the kidnapping. He told television presenter Jeremy Kyle,
菲尔·格林的电话被打爆了，客户们纷纷出价十倍于克洛伊·艾灵平时的费用来预订这位声名大噪的模特。他一次又一次地给克洛伊打电话，但唯一一次有人接听时，电话那头的一个男人自称是她的新经纪人，毫不客气地告诉菲尔他被解雇了。受到伤害和愤怒的菲尔将他的挫败感带到了各大采访节目中，声称自己因为与绑架相关的开销而自掏腰包蒙受损失。他告诉电视主持人杰瑞米·凯尔：
I'm hacked off because Chloe has had the most amazing year with the agency. In his book, Confessions of a Model Agent, Phil claimed he had done everything in his power to assist Chloe and that he was her lifeline while she was being held by the authorities in Italy. She had begged him to call her two to three times each day, with each call lasting a minimum of one hour. Chloe's recollection differed entirely. In her own memoir titled Kidnapped, The Untold Story of My Abduction, Chloe said Phil was
“我很火大，因为克洛伊这一年跟经纪公司的合作棒极了。”菲尔在他的书《模特经纪人的自白》（Confessions of a Model Agent）中声称，他已经尽其所能地帮助克洛伊，在她被意大利当局扣留期间，他是她的救命稻草。她曾恳求他每天给他打电话两到三次，每次通话至少持续一小时。而克洛伊的回忆则完全不同。克洛伊在她自己的回忆录《被绑架：我绑架案背后的未讲故事》（Kidnapped, The Untold Story of My Abduction）中说，菲尔在
extremely unhelpful during her abduction and even told her mother to stop calling him when the search was on to find her. Chloe blamed Phil for her predicament, believing he had not done his due diligence before sending her overseas to meet Andre Lattio. One telephone call was all it would have taken to confirm that the photographer, studio and agency never existed. Chloe's story was covered by every news outlet in the UK, with the public backlash swift and vicious.
她被绑架期间极其不帮忙，甚至在搜寻她的行动展开时告诉她母亲不要再打电话给他。克洛伊将自己的困境归咎于菲尔，认为他在派她出国见安德烈·拉蒂奥之前没有尽到尽职调查的义务。只需要一个电话，就能确认摄影师、照相馆和经纪公司根本不存在。克洛伊的故事被英国各大新闻媒体争相报道，公众的强烈反弹既迅猛又恶毒。
People were quick to note that her jovial demeanor did not correspond with someone who had just been through a traumatic experience, with many voicing their opinion that Chloe was lapping up the attention and not acting the way a real victim should. Every headline about the case had the words kidnap and victim in inverted commas, suggesting they were not accurate descriptors. Screenshots taken from CCTV footage showing Chloe and Wukash walking hand in hand were used to imply her involvement in the plot, as was the previous meeting they had in Paris, which ran with the headline, Chloe Knew Her Kidnapper.
人们很快指出，她那欢快愉悦的神情与刚刚经历过创伤的人不符，许多人纷纷发表意见，认为克洛伊是在博取关注，并没有表现得像一个真正的受害者。关于这起案件的每一个标题都将“绑架”和“受害者”这两个词加上了引号，暗示它们并不是准确的描述。从监控录像中截取的显示克洛伊和武卡什手牵手走在一起的画面，被用来暗示她参与了这场阴谋，他们之前在巴黎的那次会面也被翻了出来，标题赫然写着：“克洛伊认识她的绑架者”。
Things got even more out of hand in the press when it was discovered that Chloe had accepted a Facebook friend request from Wukash Herber two years prior to the kidnapping. Chloe justified there was nothing suspicious about the connection, explaining she accepted any and every friend request to network and raise her profile. Chloe's new agent negotiated increasingly higher fees for an interview with her, and she appeared on many high-profile interview shows, including 60 Minutes, where she outright blamed Phil Green's failure to perform adequate research into Andre Latio for her kidnapping. In an interview with Dr Phil, the celebrity psychologist raised doubts about Chloe's
当人们发现克洛伊在绑架事件发生两年前就接受了武卡什·赫贝尔的好友请求时，媒体的报道变得更加失控。克洛伊辩解说，这种联系并没有什么可疑之处，并解释说她接受任何和所有的好友请求是为了建立人脉并提升自己的知名度。克洛伊的新经纪人为她的采访谈判了不断水涨船高的费用，她出现在许多高调的访谈节目中，包括《60分钟》（60 Minutes），并在节目中直言不讳地将菲尔·格林未能对安德烈·拉蒂奥进行充分调查归咎为她被绑架的原因。在接受心理医生Dr Phil的采访时，这位名人心理学家对克洛伊的
story, telling her, If this was a publicity stunt gone wrong, the time to say so and stop this runaway train is now. He was one of many interviewers who treated her story with skepticism, but stopped short of calling her an outright liar. Chloe was offered £5,000 to appear in an interview with UK breakfast program Good Morning Britain, in which the host, Piers Morgan, accused her of lying about her ordeal. As in all her other interviews, Chloe came across as unemotional and aloof, appearing
故事提出了质疑，对她说：“如果这是一场出了岔子的公关噱头，现在就是承认并叫停这列失控列车的时机。”他是众多对她的故事持怀疑态度但又没有直接称她为骗子的采访者之一。克洛伊被邀请参加英国早餐节目《早安英国》（Good Morning Britain）的采访，出场费为5000英镑，节目主持人皮尔斯·摩根指责她对自己的遭遇撒谎。和她之前的所有采访一样，克洛伊表现得冷漠而疏离，
to have the glimmer of a smirk on her face. Her lack of emotion, coupled with her willingness to promote the situation for publicity and profit, did not sit well with a majority of the public, who labelled her an attention seeker. In February 2018, Wilcash Herber faced trial in Milan, appearing happy and relaxed as he entered the courtroom. His defence team argued that Wilcash had become infatuated with Chloe and that the whole ordeal had been set up by her.
脸上似乎还带着一丝假笑。她缺乏情感的表现，再加上她愿意利用这一处境进行公关和牟利，让大多数公众无法接受，他们给她贴上了“炒作狂”的标签。2018年2月，威尔卡什·赫贝尔（Wilcash Herber）在米兰受审，他进入法庭时显得高兴而放松。他的辩护团队辩称，威尔卡什对克洛伊迷恋至极，整个事件都是由她一手策划的。
They pointed to the fact that they had been Facebook friends since March 2015 and presented the CCTV footage of the two holding hands in VU. A neighbour of the farmhouse where Chloe was held testified that he had seen Chloe with Wilcash at least twice and that from a distance it looked like they were a couple. Wilcash told the court that Chloe had been complicit in the plan from the start, saying she wanted to be a model and she wanted to go on reality TV. She said she wanted to raise her profile and that it would be useful to her career to create a scandal.
他们指出两人自2015年3月起就是脸书好友，并出示了两人在VU手牵手的监控录像。克洛伊被囚禁的那栋农舍的一位邻居作证说，他曾至少两次看到克洛伊和威尔卡什在一起，从远处看他们就像是一对情侣。威尔卡什在法庭上称，克洛伊从一开始就同谋了这个计划，并说她想成为一名模特，想上真人秀节目。她说她想提高知名度，制造一场绯闻对她的事业很有帮助。
She needed help and so I decided to help her. She had a site where if you paid money you could see spicy photographs. She has no money so I said I would help her. I hoped that at the end she would remember me and we could be together. I loved her. I never hurt the girl. I was not violent with her. If she felt forced to verbally in any way I am very sorry but it certainly was not as
“她需要帮助，所以我决定帮她。她有一个网站，只要付钱就能看到大尺度照片。她没有钱，所以我说我会帮她。我希望最后她能记住我，我们能在一起。我爱过这个女孩。我从来没有伤害过她。我对她并不暴力。如果她在言语上有任何感到被迫的地方，我深表歉意，但事情绝对不像
Chloe has described. I was in love and I was hoping that once her fame took off that she would repay me with feelings and we would share the money. In his testimony Wilcash claimed he had told Chloe about the plan when she was in Paris but she was unhappy with the location he proposed she be kept in so he changed the plan to Milan. He admitted to creating the fake auction website claiming Chloe helped him write the extortion emails to Phil Green. His story changed continually and he contradicted himself often without noticing.
克洛伊所描述的那样。我当时陷入爱河，并希望一旦她成名，她会用感情回报我，我们一起分享这笔钱。”在证词中，威尔卡什声称他在巴黎时就将这个计划告诉了克洛伊，但她对关押她的地点不满意，于是他将计划改到了米兰。他承认创建了虚构的拍卖网站，并声称克洛伊帮他写了勒索菲尔·格林的邮件。他的说法一直在变，而且经常在不自知的情况下前后矛盾。
He flat out denied ever telling the Italian police he had leukaemia and his delusions became so strong and obvious that his lawyer requested a mental health assessment partway through the trial. Chloe did not have to appear at the trial with the court relying on the testimony she had given in the proceedings shortly after her release. The prosecution believed he intended to carry out the kidnapping during the original trip to Paris but backed out after being spooked by the terror attack. They described Wilcash as a fantasist with narcissistic tendencies and used evidence gained
他断然否认自己曾对意大利警方说过他患有白血病，他的妄想症变得如此强烈和明显，以至于他的律师在审判进行到一半时要求进行心理健康评估。克洛伊无需出庭受审，法庭采纳了她在她获释后不久的诉讼程序中所作的证词。检方认为他原本打算在最初的巴黎之行期间实施绑架，但在被恐怖袭击吓退后放弃了。他们将威尔卡什描述为具有自恋倾向的空想家，并利用从他的手机和电脑中获取的证据，论证了他花费数月时间策划绑架的过程。
from his phone and computer to argue that he had spent months planning the kidnapping. Shortly before Chloe's abduction he had ordered ski masks and gloves over the internet and had repeatedly used his personal computer to google the terms Chloe ailing, black death, sex trafficking and ketamine. During his time in police custody, Wilcash phoned his mother and asked her to dump his car and delete his emails, unaware that all calls made within the prison were recorded. As he gave his mother the password to his computer, investigators had no trouble accessing his files.
在克洛伊被绑架前不久，他在网上订购了滑雪面罩和手套，并多次用个人电脑在谷歌上搜索“克洛伊·艾灵、黑死神、人口贩运和氯胺酮”等词汇。在警方羁押期间，威尔卡什给母亲打电话，要求她扔掉他的车并删除他的电子邮件，却不知道监狱内的所有通话都被录音了。由于他将电脑密码告诉了母亲，调查人员毫无困难地获取了他的文件。
They found correspondence between Wilcash and his brother Mihael with one message instructing — buy a big trip back, very big. You know for what purpose it serves, so you know how big it should be. In another, Mihael advised Wilcash to be kind to Chloe as she would be more willing to cooperate. Investigators didn't find a single record of any message, email or telephone call between the Herber brothers and Chloe. On June 11, 2018, Wilcash Herber was convicted of kidnapping Chloe ailing and sentenced to 16 years and 9 months in prison.
他们发现了威尔卡什和他的兄弟米哈尔（Mihael）之间的通信，其中一条信息指示：“——买一个大的旅行包，非常大。你知道它是用来干什么的，所以你知道它应该有多大。”在另一条信息中，米哈尔建议威尔卡什对克洛伊好一点，这样她会更愿意配合。调查人员没有找到任何关于赫贝尔兄弟与克洛伊之间发送过的信息、电子邮件或电话的记录。2018年6月11日，威尔卡什·赫贝尔因绑架克洛伊·艾灵罪名成立，被判处16年零9个月监禁。
The court found no evidence to suggest Chloe had been complicit in her own abduction. This should have been total vindication for Chloe. However, the press continued with the narrative that she had masterminded the whole scheme and continued to shed doubt with headlines like, British model Chloe ailing helped write her own ransom note. It was only when reading the full article that it became clear this was not a fact but a claim made by Wilcash Herber. Chloe's story never wavered.
法院没有发现任何证据表明克洛伊参与了自己的绑架。这本应是对克洛伊的彻底平反。然而，媒体继续散布她一手策划了整个阴谋的论调，并用诸如“英国模特克洛伊·艾灵协助写下了自己的勒索信”这样的标题继续制造怀疑。只有在阅读了完整文章后，才会发现这并非事实，而是威尔卡什·赫贝尔的一面之词。克洛伊的说法从未动摇过。
Police, investigators and the court authorities in Italy and England had checked every detail and ultimately supported her story. But many members of the British press and public simply refused to believe that someone who looked and acted like Chloe was the victim of a violent crime. Regardless, Chloe defiantly continued to capitalize on her new notoriety, competing on reality TV show Celebrity Big Brother for a rumoured fee of £75,000. She was embroiled in a scandal with a married contestant and was the second person voted out of the competition.
意大利和英国的警察、调查人员以及法院当局核实了每一个细节，最终支持了她的说法。然而，英国的许多媒体和公众就是不肯相信一个外表和行为像克洛伊这样的人会成为暴力犯罪的受害者。尽管如此，克洛伊仍然公然利用她的新名气变现，传闻以7.5万英镑的出场费参加了真人秀节目《名人老大哥》（Celebrity Big Brother）。她卷入了一场与已婚参赛者的绯闻中，并成为第二个被投票淘汰的选手。
The father of Chloe's son gave interviews saying Chloe had not been to visit her child since she had returned home from Italy, preferring to travel the world following her sudden heightened fame. She also ran into trouble with the lawyer who had assisted her in Italy, with a disagreement arising between the pair over whether his services had been performed pro bono. A court subsequently ruled Chloe had to pay the lawyer £9,000 in unpaid legal fees. In May 2019, she started a new job with an adult website, Studio 66 TV, charging visitors £2 per minute to watch her strip and engage in what was advertised as sexy chat, in some
克洛伊儿子的父亲接受采访时表示，克洛伊自意大利回家后一直没有去探望孩子，而是趁着突然暴涨的名气到处环游世界。她还与曾协助她的意大利律师产生了纠纷，双方对于这些法律服务是否属于无偿提供各执一词。法院随后裁定克洛伊必须向该律师支付9000英镑的未付律师费。2019年5月，她在成人网站 Studio 66 TV 找到了一份新工作，向访问者收取每分钟2英镑的费用，观看她脱衣并进行广告中宣传的性感聊天，在某些
instances wearing a pink chenille bodysuit akin to the one she wore during her abduction. Denying any involvement in the kidnapping plot, Mihal Herber fought to avoid extradition from the UK to Italy to face trial. In December 2017, he was granted permission to appeal the decision at Westminster Magistrates Court, with the solicitors releasing a statement arguing the entire case was a sham and that there was no evidence of Mihal being involved in any of the alleged conduct. They believed he would not receive a fair trial in Italy given his brothers had already commenced.
情况下，她穿着一件粉色雪尼尔连体衣，类似于她被绑架时穿的那件。米哈尔·赫伯否认参与绑架阴谋，并极力避免被引渡回意大利接受审判。2017年12月，他获得批准在威斯敏斯特地方法院对该决定提出上诉，其律师事务所发表声明称整个案件是一场骗局，没有任何证据表明米哈尔参与了任何所谓的违法行为。他们认为，由于他的兄弟们已经开始受审，他在意大利无法得到公正的审判。
The appeal was rejected, and Mihal was eventually extradited to Italy in October 2018. Despite Chloe initially being told she would not be required to provide evidence in court, Mihal won an appeal requiring her to be questioned over her alleged involvement. As she expressed feeling vulnerable about returning to the city where she had been abducted two years earlier, she was permitted to appear from the Westminster Magistrates Court via video link. She continued to stick by every word of her original story, and denied the Defence Council's claims that she orchestrated her kidnapping as a publicity stunt to boost her public profile.
上诉被驳回，米哈尔最终于2018年10月被引渡到意大利。尽管最初有人告诉克洛伊她不需要在法庭上提供证据，但米哈尔赢得了一项上诉，要求对她涉嫌参与的行为进行盘问。由于她表示对重返两年前被绑架的城市感到不安，她被允许通过视频连线从威斯敏斯特地方法院出庭。她坚持自己最初说过的每一个字，并否认辩护律师关于她自导自演绑架案以提高公众知名度的说法。
Chloe said the whole incident had completely ruined her reputation, and it had never been her choice to go public with the details. As of June 2019, Mihal Herber's trial is still underway. Chloe has since had time to reflect on her ordeal and the public's perception of her. In a 2018 interview with the Guardian News site, she said, I don't think people believed me because I wasn't in tears, but I was happy, as you would be, seeing your family after a month when you thought you weren't going to again. Also, because cameras are an everyday part of my life, I probably reacted differently
克洛伊表示，整个事件彻底毁了她的名誉，公开这些细节从来都不是她自己的选择。截至2019年6月，米哈尔·赫伯的审判仍在进行中。此后，克洛伊有时间反思自己的遭遇以及公众对她的看法。在2018年接受《卫报》新闻网站采访时，她说：“我认为人们不相信我，是因为我没有哭泣，但我当时很高兴——当你以为再也见不到家人一个月后又见到他们时，你也会高兴。此外，由于镜头是我日常生活的一部分，我的反应可能与大多数人经历同样的事情时不同。”
from how most people would if they had been through the same thing. I think if you're going to be a glamour model, you're bound to be portrayed in that way. It's just the stereotype, I guess, that we want fame and publicity. In her book Kidnapped, the Untold Story of My Abduction, Chloe wrote, Every single word printed in this book is the truth. If you still think this is a fictitious story that I have made up because I'm an attention seeker, I suggest you read something else. I don't have time for you or your scepticism.
“我想，如果你要当一个迷人的模特，你注定会被那样描绘。我想这只是一种刻板印象，认为我们渴望名利和出名。”克洛伊在她的书《绑架：我被绑架的内幕故事》中写道：“这本书中印刷的每一个字都是真的。如果你仍然认为这是一个虚构的故事，是我为了博取关注而捏造的，我建议你读点别的。我没有时间应付你或你的怀疑。”
Going through what I have gone through has taught me one thing. You never know what is going to happen. You never know what is round the corner. You have to live every moment. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
经历了我所经历的一切，我明白了一个道理。你永远不知道会发生什么。你永远不知道转角会遇到什么。你必须活在当下。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。